الترس نادي نابولي يعيد مسروقات للمدرب
اسبانيتي
رئيس رابطه الليغا يسخر من ريال مدريد
وبرشلونه
على مشروع قانون لمحاربه العنصريه
هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
لا تزالوا جماهير نابولي تخطف الاضواء بعد
تتويج الفريق بلقب الدوري الايطالي وهذه
المره اهدى التراس فريق الجنوب مقودان
لمدرب الفريق سبالتي وهو مقود سيارته التي
سرقت من طرف الجماهير الفريق التي كانت
غاضبه عليه قبل نحو سنتين من الان بسبب
الاداء السيء للفريق اعادته هذه القطعه هو
هديه وداع بعد ان قررت مغادره النادي وهو
الشرط الذي وضعه الالتراس لاعاده السياره
الى صاحبها
وبعد الاخبار التي تحدثت عن خروج نادي
يوفنتوس الايطالي من بطوله السوبر رئيس
رابطه الدوري الاسباني خافي ارتباس وهو
احد وهو احد اشد المعارضين للمشروع
للسخريه من ريال مدريد وبرشلونه عبر
تغريده قال فيها بان اخر المغادرين عليه
اطفال الاضواء وغلق الباب خلفه اقتباس
قصده بهذه التغريده فريق ريال مدريد
وبرشلونه لذاني سيبقيان لوحدهما ان قرر
الفريق الايطالي الانسحاب من السوبرليك
تتويج نابولي بلقب الدوري الايطالي فتح
الباب امام نجومه للمغادره نحو اقوى الفرق
الاوروبيه لكن مدافع الكوري الجنوبي
كيمنجي يواجه مشكله تحول بينه وبين
الانضمام لمانشستر يونايتد الذي قدم عرضا
لضم اللاعب وهي تاديه الخدمه العسكريه
الخدمه في كوريا مدتها سنتان لكن كما
استفاد من استثناء كونه ساهم في فوز منتخب
بلاده بالميداليه الذهبيه في الالعاب
الاسيويه عام 2018 لتخفف المده الى بضعه
اسابيع وهو ما حدث ايضا مع سون نجم
توتنهام الانجليزي
صدقت ولايه ريو دي جانيرو على مشروع قانون
يقضي بوقف مباريات كره القدم حال حدوث
اساءه عنصريه وهذا بعد الاهانات التي تعرض
لها فينيسيوس جونيور لاعب ريال مدريد
والتي تسببت بردود فعل قويه حول العالم
وادت الى عده توقيفات مصحوبه بعقوبات
شديده